today is a good day fellow Scholars why
is that because we are going to talk
about this this and this three
incredible new papers that will help you
Unleash Your creativity like never
before and a word about Google deep
Minds Gemini AI at the end of the video
first let's try to become a virtual film
director and create videos but wait one
of our previous episodes was exactly on
that yes but here you get to be a
director but not in the way you think so
how well first let's start with a
photograph now get this Google's earlier
AI helps us to fly into this
photo that is incredible it even
supports curved camera motions and
long-term videos however there is is a
problem what is the problem as you see
long-term coherence is not the greatest
the scene seems to deviate further and
further away from the origin photo of
course because it has to make up a lot
of stuff but there is a follow-up paper
on this this is better but the issues
still remain the same but we learned
something important here whatever the
new solution is going to look like now
we know that we should be evaluating it
on quality and coherence now let's have
a look at a new text to video technique
it promises zero shot scene generation
that is incredible what is that it means
that it is able to generate scenes with
these prompts kind of like an artist
painting a landscape that they have
never seen before it did not have access
to similar videos in his training data
and yet here it is I love it and back to
Quality and coherence in my opinion we
have higher quality results and
coherence is really good too all we need
is just a piece of text input so how how
is this even possible well I will tell
you in a moment dear fellow Scholars
this is two minute papers with Dr
car now let's compare it to PR previous
techniques this is against runways gen
one we showcased this in an earlier
video too H do you see what I see here
yes it is not your eyes the output seems
a little slower gen one indeed generates
a few duplicate frames otherwise not bad
this is a tool that is already being
used out there to create movie projects
not feature length movies but do not let
that fool you AI film festivals are
already being held where people put
together videos of 1 to 10 minutes in
length not 5-second videos anymore
prizes are also given out and if that
fires you up you can also submit your
own work too today everybody can become
an artist and take part in this what an
incredible time to be alive right so
that was gen one I will note that gen 2
also exist to the best of my knowledge
without a paper and now let's compare
gen one to the new technique and the new
technique wow this is an incredible jump
in just one paper and gen one appeared
not years ago but less than a year ago
such an improvement in less than one
year and as always just imagine what we
will be capable of just two more papers
down the line my goodness but we are not
done yet not even close now hold on to
your papers fellow Scholars and let's
see how it performs against another
technique from this year and for me this
is once again wow really this kind of
improvement in just one paper is very
impressive now look here because this is
super important what is this well fellow
Scholars this is the mesh representation
of the scene digital 3D geometry and I
hear you asking great now we can put it
into our video games that is important
but caroy is that super
important yes it is you see meshes are
essential in understanding this work and
here comes one of my favorite things
about this paper first first it starts
out with a mesh structure digital
geometry and over time this AI is like a
sculptor who is working on a clay model
yes as the camera moves around it grows
this mesh outwards loving it now this
was text to video and also text to 3D
geometry but now wait a second text
prompts are great but what if we already
have an image of our scene instead but
that's just a 2D image and we would like
3D geometry instead well have a look at
this paper oh yeah it promises that it
takes just this one image and it guesses
what is around it and what is behind it
in a coherent manner well it promises
that but I will believe it when I see it
whoo look at that it's not perfect by
any any means but it is real good and
good is an important keyword why well
take it from the legendary chip engineer
Jim Keller and there's a website or a
YouTube channel called two-minute papers
he says this rule is if it's good it's
just two papers away from being great
and this is going to happen pretty fast
that was an incredibly good summary of
what you see here and a huge honor thank
you so yes if it's good two more papers
down the line and it will be great so we
can now create these videos from text or
a photograph but get this you might not
even need a photograph to perform all
this yes that's right with the third
paper today you can even have a photo
that is almost completely destroyed and
it will be able to restore it really
well and this can then go into into the
photo to 3D techniques can you imagine
before watching 2minute papers that
someone says that from this photo and
two AI research papers and it will be
restored with amazingly high quality and
then you can even put it into a video
game no one would have believed it and
yet here we are wow now note that of
course image in painting techniques
already exist there are heaps and heaps
of papers on it for instance here is a
legendary paper patch match from 14
years ago all handcrafted human
Ingenuity a graphics paper of course
that was really impressive but compared
to what we can do today wow I am out of
words what a time to be alive now as
promised a word about Gemini we
discussed it in detail a few videos ago
and I I made sure that we mainly discuss
results not from the marketing materials
but from the research paper itself we
are fellow Scholars here and paper
results are more detailed and easier to
verify however while I was talking I
also showed you some materials like this
in the meantime Google discussed how
this footage was made and it was made
not with the AI realtime feedback on a
video but they used still images from
the video plus wrote a prompt to give it
to the AI the answers were then showed
here and these prompts range from simple
like what do you see here to something
more detailed however we did not see
these prompts I think best would have
been if it were presented in a way like
you see here and second best would have
been adding a disclaimer to the footage
that still images and additional
prompting was used the paper results
that span the majority of our videos are
to the best of my knowledge accurate I
wanted to make really sure to revisit
this just to make sure that you always
get accurate information about these
works that is the way of the scholar
when I was a PhD student my experiments
created lots of data for my deep
learning projects but I was not looking
for more data I was looking for insights
this is what weights and biases does and
and it is the best everyone is using it
try it out now at wb. me/ papers or
click the link in the description below